the hall ladies and gentlemen my name is
Gregory alpha Greg Allegretti cuz I'm
relatable yes they see how my readers I
can't be any pants over here all right
sir Gregory what are we lost based age
here s oh how r 2012 on Twitter yes and
Stacey Oh Howard on Instagram yes yes I
should know that I'm looking at it
constable oh no oh yeah well if a little
of that I'm a little um yeah yeah yeah
yeah I go to town why are these videos
always like this with us I'm sorry I no
no that's okay we're watching a video
right now though a horror movie it comes
at night see you ms it comes a nice
teaser trailer I have to insert that I
don't know what it's about all right or
is my favorite
I think that will and I see the only one
to go outside for a while we all know
what makes them sick you know anything
nobody cuts himself or fine I positive
use open door all right you're going I
think us to do yeah what
it was arguably what the door was
already open together yeah
welcome
a 22 north
[Music]
if you're lying ok
[Music]
dallas like my kind of film no it's yeah
that whoa ah I've chilled everywhere
that's fantastic looking so when I
described the people like what my
favorite kind of movie is watch this
trailer this is it I love horror movies
I love darkest us movies and thrillers
and things that make you really
uncomfortable and disturb you that looks
exactly like something that I would want
to see ya reminds me of this indie film
that I saw a sleepwalker it's got brady
corbet one of the actors from that who's
also in girls is installing this trailer
hey master so same kind of tone same
kind of look fantastic so I'm sold like
you know I don't see anything else even
it was just that first shot I'd be like
all right I like films where they're
like in a rather contained environment
cuz look how are going to take place
dislike cabin in the woods are so many
like that yeah we got masks on Boris is
such a big part of its atmosphere seems
like this is going to be a lot about
that must be removed adding all this
area tension and suspense and we're
going like a logical mind [ __ ] like is
it ours is there actually something
that's out there or are they just like
crazy today waited like what's happening
is it real is it all psychological is it
was going to be like the village yeah
normal it's just idiots real is real
life yeah its current game and they're
all living inside of animal thank you it
was for the villains you guys are gonna
be someone we like you focus you did
with ginger I'll be like alright calm
the [ __ ] down yes my hair you can't
change your people have told you that
yeah sometimes ginger just my mom nah
yeah happen my mom called me a Filipino
dumbass oh I'm like mom you're the
Filipino one in the fam little are we
look like a wish to me yeah all the
which one of my favorite movie the last
year I need to rewatch that is that
screaming so
where I feel like it's on like it's on
DVD all right the way the cinematography
frames everything you going wide shots
everyone's very much centered ya ain't
got the wood bloom and the long shot
yeah like the long panning shot yeah the
opening shot of this clip that they kept
coming back and forth you an other
insert so they kept going on that red
door what's behind a [ __ ] war I've
got to know what's behind that door I
don't know we're gonna find out when we
see this movie because I'm going opening
weekend to see this yeah this looks
great this is one of those things where
like I'll Drive 30 minutes out of the
way into a theater that you know not
close to me to just to see it as like
you know on a Tuesday night because I do
stuff like that looks Louise the IMDb
fought all right secure within a
desolate home as an unnatural threat
terrorize of the world you could take it
around a man has established a tenuous
domestic order with his wife and son but
this will soon be put to test when a
desperate young family arrive seeking
refuge protecting ya [ __ ] [ __ ]
come in and said we want what you have a
mental engines like me and then so the
family over there must be like the
creepy ones already or they're not
protect themselves against something
yeah it's just right even real is this
something really this happening in the
world or is everyone like going crazy
all I know is this is a good trailer in
Joel Edgerton excels in any dominant
don't happen you see Exodus gods and
kings uh you know I walked every other
line man if I wanted to see his pale
white me insane boba is clearly an
Egyptian you guys obviously and he
directed the road and dress of a gift so
this case horror this guy knows they're
absolutely this movie also reminds me of
oh oh there's a film that everyone needs
to watch is called we are what we are
and it's on I think it's still on
netflix and I'm not going to tell you
anything about it just watch it it's
going to have I guarantee you the same
fantastic tone and atmosphere and he's
like psychological [ __ ] you up miss as
this we are where we are I think it's on
that like well I promotions in one video
I am throwing those indie films at you
all the time
you guys all in q2 22 yes there you go
all right guys guys thanks for telling
us that was out well my hair looks great
you look fantastic if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe today there
everybody's regex and Stacy do you want
to just ring that happen in this place
sweaty and on the inside because I took
a shower and then you came over and I
were like I don't have time to comb my
hair put the pad on I don't think I
don't you sweat profusely anymore all
right okay I saw a lot of glistening I
think whoo okay to combat the Glen
condition I have okay I don't sweat
cyber one of your medical condition
reminding me about my orphanage cut it
out cop stacy is on hitter his movie six
degrees of each her film and she is soo
our 2012 on Twitter Stacy Oh Howard on
Instagram damn I got it right for videos
in social media win job kiddo pravi oh
and we're gonna be versing each other on
the movie trivia Schmo down I've been
going down oh you're going I am yours no
idea I am hey watch i'm watching movies
all day mm-hmm what was it nothing what
definitely wasn't a sexual joke at all
we never do those what's sex nothing to
go back to a previous video you got to
go back you walk you can decide oh ah
inside okay